el campamento de del río texas se ha
quedado vacío las autoridades
estadounidenses trasladaron a miles de
emigrantes de la zona intentando poner
fin así a la crisis migratoria en la
frontera con méxico
murias de esta mañana ya no hay
inmigrantes en el campamento bajo el
puente internacional desde el río sobre
el campamento llegó a acumular cerca de
15 mil personas y dejó imágenes que
dieron la vuelta al mundo de la policía
dando un trato inhumano a los migrantes
algo por lo que el presidente ballena
prometió responsabilidades
por supuesto que asumo la
responsabilidad soy el presidente es
horrible lo que hemos visto ver a la
gente siendo tratada de esa forma
caballos pasándolo por encima gente
amarrada es indignante les prometo que
esa gente pagará hay una investigación
en curso y habrá consecuencias
ante la política de expulsiones de eeuu
y el trato recibido cientos de migrantes
regresaron a méxico donde ahora piden
asilo no obstante el gobierno de lópez
obrador advirtió que no planea una
acogida masiva
no queremos que méxico sea un campamento
de migrantes queremos que se atiendan
el problema de fondo de la gente no se
vea obligada
a emigrar
porque si no continuamos con lo mismo el
dirigente mexicano también pidió la
intervención de la onu en apoyo a haití
de donde proceden la mayoría de los
migrantes de que vamos a subsistir